♪
>> Sean: WELCOME BACK TO
SPECIAL EDITION OF HANNITY
HERE WITH MORE ACTION TO MY
MONOLOGUE, FORMER U.S.
ATTORNEY FOR THE DISTRICT OF
COLUMBIA JOE DIGENOVA AND
THE PERSON THAT THE PRESS
SAID WOULD NEVER BE BACK ON
MY SHOW THE AUTHOR OF
TRUMPED UP HARVARD LAW
SCHOOL PROFESSOR PROFESSOR
ALAN DERSHOWITZ IS WITH US.
LET ME ASK YOU BOTH THE SAME
QUESTION, I WILL START WITH
YOU, JOE, THIS IS FROM THE
COMEY MEMO U IF THERE WAS
SOME SATELLITE, MEANING HE
SAID I TOOK THIS TO BE
ASSOCIATE OF HIS CAMPAIGN IF
THEY DID SOMETHING, THIS IS
TRUMP TO COMEY, IT WOULD BE
GOOD TO FIND THAT OUT.
BUT THAT HE, HIMSELF HADN'T
DONE ANYTHING.
THAT SOUNDS TO ME LIKE HE IS
ENCOURAGING THE FBI DIRECTOR
TO LOOK NO ALL OF THIS AND
EVEN IF IT IS SOMEBODY CLOSE
TO HIM, TO FIND OUT THE
TRUTH.
SO, A, IS HE NOT OBSTRUCTING
JUSTICE, AND, B, IS HE
ENCOURAGING THE
INVESTIGATION TO GO FORWARD.
>> WELL, I DON'T THINK THERE
IS ANY DOUBT THAT THESE 15
PAGES OF JAMES COMEY'S NOTES
CONSTITUTE A SUICIDE NOTE, A
LENGTHY SUICIDE NOTE.
IT SHOWS CLEARLY.
>> Sean: YOU DO HAVE A WAY
WITH WORDS.
YOU KNOW THAT.
>> HE HAS DECEIVED WELL, I
MEAN, THIS STUFF IS PRETTY
OBVIOUS.
HE HAS DECEIVED CONGRESS AS
A RESULT OF THIS SUBSTANCE
IN THESE MEMORANDA.
HE HAS DECEIVED THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE.
AND I MUST SAY HE HAS
DILUTED HIMSELF.
IT IS QUITE OBVIOUS THAT THE
PRESIDENT IS AN INNOCENT MAN
AND THAT THE COLLUSION
THEORY HAS BEEN RIDICULOUS
FROM THE BEGINNING.
>> Sean: AND OBSTRUCTION.
>> YES.
BUT THESE MEMORANDUMS SHOW
CONCLUSIVELY THAT JAMES
COMEY KNEW THAT FROM THE
VERY BEGINNING.
HE HID IT FROM THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE.
HE HID IT FROM CONGRESS.
I MUST SAY THAT AS HE GOES
ON THIS RIDICULOUS TOUR, HE
IS DESTROYING THE FEDERAL
BUREAU OF INVESTIGATION AND
I CAN TELL YOU, SEAN, FROM
CONVERSATIONS WITH PEOPLE
INSIDE THAT BUILDING AT
HEADQUARTERS, THEY ARE VERY,
VERY DISAPPOINTED AND VERY
ANGRY PEOPLE WHO BELIEVES HE
IS DESTROYING A GREAT
INSTITUTION.
>> Sean: I WANT TO REMIND
PEOPLE -- I DON'T EVER WANT
TO SWEEP WITH A BROAD BRUSH
HERE.
THERE ARE MEN AND WOMEN THAT
RISK THEIR LIVES IN THAT
ORGANIZATION.
IN OUR CIA, IN OUR
INTELLIGENCE COMMUNITY, THAT
PUT THEIR LIVES ON THE LINE.
WE CANNOT -- WE CANNOT JUDGE
THEM BY THE CONDUCT OF A
COUPLE OF PEOPLE HERE.
>> ABSOLUTELY CORRECT.
>> I AGREE COMPLETELY.
AND NONE OF US HAS, BY THE
WAY.
WE HAVE ALL SAID IT'S THE
HIERARCHY.
IT'S THE MCCABES.
IT'S THE COMEY, IT'S GOT
NOTHING TO DO WITH THE RANK
AND FILE.
THEY ARE ANGRY AT WHAT COMEY
IS DOING THAT.
>> Sean: I APPRECIATE THAT.
>> SEVERAL YEARS AGO MY LIFE
WAS THREATENED BY A INMATE
IN FEDERAL PRISON NEO NAZI.
AND THE FBI ASSIGNED TWO
AGENTS TO ME FULL TIME.
THEY CAME TO MY CLASS.
THEY CAME WITH ME TO BOSTON
CELTICS BASKETBALL GAMES.
AND I REALLY GOT TO JUST
LOVE THESE TWO GUYS.
THEY GAVE ME THEIR HOME
NUMBERS.
NO MATTER WHAT, 24/7 I COULD
CALL THEM.
THEY PROTECTED ME.
THEY PROTECTED MY FAMILY.
YOU KNOW, I WAS BROUGHT UP
TO LOVE LAW ENFORCEMENT.
I WAS A MEMBER OF THE POLICE
ATHLETIC LEAGUE AS A KID.
I REPRESENT POLICEMEN ANY
LAW ENFORCEMENT PEOPLE FREE
OF CHARGE BECAUSE WE OWE
THEM SO MUCH.
BUT I HAVE TO AGREE WITH YOU
AND IT STARTED IN BOSTON A
LONG, LONG TIME AGO WHEN THE
WHITEY BULGER MATTER CAME UP
AND WE SAW HOW PEOPLE AT
EVERY LEVEL COVERED FOR HIM
AND ALLOWED INNOCENT PEOPLE
TO REMAIN IN PRISON.
IT'S SO IMPORTANT TO FATHER
RIT
FATHER RITOUT THE BAD GUYS.
JOHN CONNOLLY.
I HELPED PUT HIM IN PRISON.
I CONSULTED PRO BONO WITH
THE PROSECUTORS TO HELP KEEP
THAT GUY IN PRISON BECAUSE
HE WAS SUCH A BAD EGG.
HE WAS TELLING WHITEY BULGER
WHO TO KILL.
HOW TO ESCAPE.
FOR 16 YEARS THE FBI
COULDN'T FIND WHITEY BULGER.
HE WAS IN PLAIN VIEW IN
SANTA MONICA, CALIFORNIA
REPORTEDLY GOING TO A RED
SOX BAR TO WATCH BASEBALL
GAMES AND THE FBI COULDN'T
FIND HIM.
FINALLY A PERSON FROM THE
FEDERAL MARSHALL PROGRAM
FOUND HIM.
SO, LOOK, I THINK WE HAVE TO
COMMEND FBI AGENTS, CIA
AGENTS AND FOCUS ON THE
PROBLEMS AND WHERE THEY
OCCUR.
>> Sean: LET ME ASK THIS
THEN.
MAYBE YOU AGREE OR DISAGREE
HERE.
LOOK AT THE CRIMINAL
REFERRALS THAT HAVE COME
DOWN THIS WEEK.
YOU KNOW, THE CONGRESSIONAL
CRIMINAL REFERRALS WITH --
THEY ARE CITING SPECIFIC
LAWS THAT THEY BELIEVE WERE
VIOLATED THEN ANDREW MCCABE
AND THE CRIMINAL IG
REFERRAL.
NOW WE HAVE AN
INVESTIGATION, JAMES COMEY,
I SAID THIS BEFORE HE WENT
ON HIS BOOK TOUR, JOE
DIGENOVA, THIS IS A BAD
IDEA.
I DON'T THINK ANY COMPETENT
LAWYER WOULD HAVE ADVISED
HIM, WRITING THAT BOOK AND
DOING THIS TOUR IN ANY WAY
BUT NOW HE IS UNDER AN
INSPECTOR GENERAL
INVESTIGATION HERE ABOUT
RELEASING CLASSIFIED
MATERIALS, 18 USC 793, BOTH
OF YOU ARE VERY FAMILIAR
WITH IT.
>> YES.
WELL, SEAN, HERE'S WHAT'S
GOING TO HAPPEN.
THIS IS NOW, IT'S ALL AFOOT.
AND IT CAN'T BE STOPPED.
THERE IS GOING TO BE A
SERIES OF FEDERAL GRAND
JURIES STRATEGY THESE
THINGS.
THE UNMASKING OF INDIVIDUALS
WHICH WAS ILLEGAL.
THE LEAKING OF THE UNMASKED
INFORMATION TO NEWSPAPERS
WHICH WERE FELONIES AND THE
OTHER THINGS THAT INVOLVE
THE MISUSE OF THE
INTELLIGENCE AND FISA
WARRANTS.
THERE IS GOING TO BE A
SERIES OF GRAND JURIES AND
HE THERE ARE GOING TO BE
CHARGES.
I DON'T KNOW WHO IS GOING TO
BE CHARGED IT'S VERY
IMPORTANT THIS BE DONE THE
RIGHT WAY.
THAT CAN ONLY BE DONE WITH
FEDERAL GRAND JURIES.
THAT'S THE WAY THE HILLARY
CLINTON CASE SHOULD HAVE
BEEN HANDLED AND IT WASN'T.
NOW WE ARE GOING TO SEE IT
DONE RIGHT.
>> IT'S SO INTERESTING
BECAUSE, OF COURSE, THIS IS
WHAT I PREDICTED FROM THE
VERY BEGINNING IN MY BOOK
"TRUMPLED UP."
ONCE YOU UNLEASH THIS
BUSINESS OF TRYING TO LOCK
HIM UP, IT'S GOING TO COME
BACK AND BITE YOU IN THE
REAR END.
TODAY DID YOU GO AFTER
TRUMP.
TOMORROW THEY GOAL AFTER
DEMOCRATS.
YOU CANNOT UNLEASH THIS
WEAPON OF EXPANDING THE
CRIMINAL LAW.
AND TARGETING PEOPLE WITHOUT
IT COMING BACK.
YOU KNOW, THERE IS THAT
GREAT LINE FROM A MAN FOR
ALL SEASONS ABOUT ONE OF THE
GREATEST LAWYERS IN HISTORY,